all right ruby
ruby uh where did you grow up where are
you from originally leslie county
you grew up in leslie county here in
kentucky yeah
how would you describe your childhood
well i'd say i had the most wonderful
childhood could have been i stayed right
behind my dad's back
we raised five acres of fall beans
peddled them through the mining camps
and then we'd take a load of groceries
back to white oak to the store from the
breaks of laurel down here all the way
to head of white oak we would sell
everybody groceries stop at their house
until we got in home and we'd be up
empty for the store when we got there
you were born what year
uh 1934.
i'll be 87 in april
87. and uh so you growing up here you
had
you i assume you had no electricity you
had no running water oh nobody didn't
have that
and uh we got water out of a coal bank
and you took sacks and went up to the
coal bank drug you cold down the hill to
the house to burn of the night to keep
us warm keep it warm
and for food you'd go where no we raised
our food i still raise food i've got
three deep priests full and a hogs to
kill and everything i don't hardly i buy
50 pounds of pinto beans at the time and
a big stand-alone like i growed up yet
big 25 pounds of sugar and salt
and you don't have to go to the store
but just like
occasionally yeah so you're in garden
oh yeah we raised everything you grow
everything
you've done that your whole life
yeah that's what i eat that's the reason
my health is nothing right i like no i
see how hard you're working yeah we we
found you here at nine o'clock this
morning and you you were coming back
from
from what were you doing
i was getting ready we got to put
electric pole up today to a trailer and
start tearing one down
and you hunt for uh
tell me what else you doing
you you do a lot you stay busy all day
long yeah i get up well usually about
five o'clock
and then i lay down maybe seven or eight
at night i get it turned in like i can
get my beautiful but you you spend your
days doing what kind of stuff
well um mainly uh
chasing renters
chasing white renters i rent property oh
you ran property so you're yeah you're
trying to get and uh the kids have to
have it for college i had to give one
boy this week four thousand dollars i
went and paid it tuition for him to get
uh
drive uh big trucks
this week so that's what the rent goes
for
and do you have children of your own oh
yeah i've got five generations
and i've schooled all of them sent them
to college so far
right now i'm getting to go and get them
college errors to drive a big tractor
and trailer
he's getting out of the mines he was
driving five hours a day to work back
so i went patty's tuition was four
thousand this week having that money
when you say you have five generations
you mean your
children have had children who have had
children yeah that's what i'm putting
this week this one trek right here this
old texaco card
it goes in the five generations it can't
be sold out of the family
and this property all belonged to my
grandfather how many acres how many
acres there is uh about 500 acres right
here in this thousand acre patton from
421 highway and you're you're up on a
mountaintop here it's beautiful yeah on
top of this mountain i had cancer it's
1970 and they closed my restaurant down
er so they said
and i i took that money and sold out and
come up here my grandfather passed away
in 1970 and bought the ears out and come
up here
and five years later i got some
insurance and had cancer surgery
and i'm still sitting right here what
kind of cancer
uh female yeah
and they closed my restaurant down i
could never understand that
you're the healthiest 87 year old i
think i've ever seen
well first i know there's nothing wrong
with me
every bit of my joints is as limber as
they can be but i got six joints of
backbone now a lot of people may hear
this
busted up in a rig
and that was about in a 55 or 56 and uh
out here to miners hospital the lady and
man was doctors from overseas and they
put me on a jell-o diet
each night you heat now you got a
microwave heat your water in just get a
cup in there
put a teaspoon full of jell-o i like
lemon and lime and now you can see how
limber and i get that guitar and i can
play anything my legs and slimmer's 15
year old yeah you move you move like
you're 30 years old
and i hit that hits that jello keeps my
gelatin in my bones and everything built
and my bones good and sturdy
it does that the jello does and your
eyesight is good too right
your eyesight is good oh yeah and you're
hearing yeah
nothing wrong no worries i know what you
don't wear glasses no
to read no to drive no still drive yeah
every day going here and there's if you
just yeah you see they say uh the bible
says long as you've got work to do
he'll keep you here so it might be me
running the roads in a truck
you're you're uh religious you go to
church
uh not since my husband died i just stay
at the house
but you you
you would consider yourself a spiritual
religious person oh yes
that's a big thing here in appalachia
isn't it yeah
usually every night before i go to bed i
play amazing grace
on the guitar and sang
and that tides me over
in my jell-o
how much schooling did you get how far
did you go on school uh i got a high
school education at berea
we worked our way down there filled
taters in the morning washed dishes of
the night
to get you that fiji
boarding
place to stay
and have you have you traveled around
the u.s around the country oh i've
drugged trailers out of aurora
and from there before i reckon in the
country you buy them off of this outfit
where they come in with flood disasters
buy them trailers for fifty to three
hundred dollars dragging all you want no
but have you traveled yeah where have
you been traveling full of trailers in
aurora is about the first way i've been
over the ocean lack there
in florida
i think it's in florida it's called
aurora and we come through tennessee
with them here
and when we get back like see this
mountain oh boy i said getting home i
don't like that level country but what
is it about appalachia that makes
makes it difficult for people to leave
because it's a difficult life we've got
i think perfect air here to keep you in
good health
and i don't know people's mind and
everything just tastes bitter
i think you're tuned into nature and
you're you're you're living the way now
me raising all my
food about it in hogs and stuff like
that the meat and my kids
uh roy is 70 year old my oldest son
and the baby is 64. lives right down
there i blow here
roy lives right down in that house you
first passed by the greenhouse
[Music]
so this this way of living
yeah it's very difficult here for people
to find jobs
well i don't know seems to me like
they're getting paid good wages but
right now with people their minds are
going out that's what i'm saying they
just took a cold all out they go over
there
here back of uh one of my granny marty
medka patented 150 acres over there back
way in the 1800s uh hair zone behind it
they set in and they went straight down
with their coal in the back of mine
and the bottom seam
was uh
nine seams
cold ten foot high that they took and
cut out and that's the reason there's no
work here they just went to the top of
the mountains and just cut the coal out
down on the down flat
into my opinion now
you know if they tuck it all out ain't
nothing to work yeah
and they went in down in in uh
greasy
and went under the mines and they went
through white oak they went through wolf
creek and they come out way on touching
busted out the mines i went all the way
through under the mountains and took the
coal out nobody knowed it nobody got no
money nobody got nothing
they took everybody's coal
that's a fact i know that because i see
where they come out at where they went
in at
they went plum like right here they went
and you see the mountains through and
they went only this down at the creek
level
and see it now you go up there there's
no water in the creeks i was baptized
where my grandfather drowned
and uh what i call it was a splash dam
and i was over there the other day and
drove by and you know what they ain't no
water over there no more date enough to
get out there and with your feet
in the whole creek
that's awful
yes and i think it's the mining
underneath us is the water's just
sinking jess pennington told me that
when i was a kid in white oak that would
make sense you're digging them he said
there'll be a day when you won't even
see no water washing down now this
branch
what do you make of
the future of this part of the world
part of this country it's coming back to
like we growed up you're gonna have to
get a medic in a hole and get out and go
to farming raising what you eat get your
milk cow back and your butter and hogs
and chickens our family's all got it we
got 212 acres i blowed this road down
here and we've got all them animals down
there
and they got four horses
so we got wagons you can hook them
wagons up and ride them anywhere you
want to go
and uh
all of the old tiny stuff is stored down
there from the founding it's a difficult
life but it seems to make appalachians a
little more resilient and
compassionate for each other they're
very kind and helpful for each their
nation well
foreign everybody is with me
everybody treats me like i'm their
sister or their mother now for any to so
many the kids like him have grown up
and i don't know no more but they know
me
it's too many
and they're so sweet
i just love them little children
what was the best time of your life
well i just wouldn't know it's all been
good
it's great it's still being good i'm
hitting the road let's get up at five
o'clock to get out ready to go and get
things done and get back about seven
do you feel like you've lived the life
you wanted to
i live it just like i want to if you
don't you've wasted the whole thing
if you sat down do what somebody else
says for you to do that ain't your uh
way of living or it ain't mine
i've never let nobody get in my way
they get in my way i'll go around them
i don't know i'll go
and your kids are doing what kind of
well uh they've all retired from jobs
but what kind of work did they do uh roy
was in uh
social services my oldest son
he went to college and he went in social
services i'm gonna get him started on
his cousin in here
and uh so uh
vern she worked at the courthouse uh
in the clerk's office till she [ __ ]
she passed away three months ago she is
66
she smoked cigarettes and got cancer of
the lungs
couldn't get rid of my towel
and my baby one he got hit in the head
with a little have a tree when he was
probably 18.
i just got three
i lost two babies
and uh at birth
and uh
so we've had a fine family
now we got five men henry's got five
generations of children which i'm going
to probably this week go to the
courthouse and get this put in the five
generations it can't be sold or
mortgaged right here we're wrong this
park property
this old texas park i come here
and walked across the hill and went over
my grandmother lived right down here
in uh june the 15th of 52
me and roy he was two years old
and we walked across this little hill
got out at the road my grandpa had a
store and we walked over and come on
over here to granny's house right down
on the hill here
and he went to work at uh jellicle
grocery which he stayed there about 30
years
and uh mine said [ __ ] down when we come
here at blue diamond
so you had to go where this work yeah
have you been to big cities yeah i've
been i guess in every city they are what
do you think of the big city
well i don't care for them i'd rather be
back here in the mountains
uh it's just too jammed up and uh
you know i like it where it's like it's
here you can look me i can look top that
mountain over here and i own it next
thing
yeah and uh i like that you don't have
any neighbors
well i got all these renters yeah but
and
i can't see another house in any
direction yeah not right here i don't
allow that because my grandpa
my dad bought out the heirs and left
this to me was just part of the state
for me
and this is the most important piece of
property i've got
is this old texaco park property
and you want to take a picture of that
big tree where the indians supposed to
supposedly come up there and watch for
people coming in on them they had terms
of watching
and they'd climb up there to get it
better they climbed the furnace see they
could see them coming up the mountains
and what kind of indians were here uh
cherokees cherokee
do you have cherokee yes you're part
cherokee yeah somewhere
uh
well i'd say probably i was a fourth or
fifth generation down
and maybe not that much i don't guess i
probably was second or third generation
and tell me about uh growing up here you
you know so you got
vehicles at what what edge you remember
oh i have got every vehicle before that
i bought since went to driving [ __ ] in
52 52 has been vehicle kind of yeah oh
that's older than that
they're down up a hill all these down
through here them down my house no but
you you went you went how many years
before the vehicle really came into this
uh
i was down at the foot of the mountain i
just really don't know in 52 i was born
34
so i didn't go to driving 34 44 54 52
18 wanted i went to driving okay so so
ought to be automobile came to
yeah i've got uh i sold two since then
since 52.
two vehicles i let go i trade them in on
two and after that i just kept them and
bought me something else
and you had outhouses i think you still
have an outhouse now don't you
uh i guess they are outhouses
didn't they see one next to your house
people to use uh
now that they made our houses they're
still old-timey antiques oh okay it
looks like an outhouse
they've got all kinds of antiques in
them but that's probably how you grew up
without houses and
yeah so i growed up that way and up here
we had them
uh pretty well till uh they put the
water around the mountain
and that's not been probably what 12 15
years ago if it's been that long yeah
and there's still people living with no
electricity no no running water today
yeah i'd say they are yeah
and a lot of people use generators
anymore
like if i rent a place from this to pull
in a camper and live they have
generators just to hook them up
back on dingo
do you have uh any regrets in your life
any regrets no i don't fool with nothing
that caused me a regret
only thing you know we always hate you
lost a baby or something like that that
you didn't
get to uh
be with
henry lived to be 85 so you can't regret
that my dad was
i think he was about 96
and then i kept my uncle and took care
of him and i'm not sure what his age was
when he passed away
i kept the family and took care of him
as they passed
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your 87 years
to be saving with my money
the youngest is going to need it the
children
and your husband did what kind of work
uh he worked in a man's
first
and then one thing i'd like to tell you
mr corman him uh james corn
they were
masons of the nolan lodge up at pine
mountain
and i'm getting ready to send to the
lawyer some pictures of mr corn right
now
and i think them is really important
things
my husband joined the nolan lodge at 22
years old we was a dating
and he couldn't hardly come on saturday
night because he had to go up there
and we dated 27 months before we got
married because i was in real school
most of the time
and i come in that fall and that summer
and i didn't go back that far we just
got married he had me a house built and
it furnished
so i just went home and i've had a home
ever since
[Laughter]
but you've lived a great life you in
your opinion i don't think that
anybody's lived the life i have and it's
all been great and i go to town
everybody hollers ruby baker ruby baker
comes running to me them kids have grown
up and i don't know who they are but i
don't tell them that i don't say
anything i just meet them and maybe hug
their neck but it's not your memory it's
just that there are so many they so many
yeah
but your memory is sharp your health is
great yeah
i've been in business uh
since i guess i was what
maybe 22 when i put up the rest of the
foot of the mountain do you think
staying busy staying working active is
the key if you sit down you know you're
gonna get big and fat and you can't get
i've got renters can't get out of their
wheelchair if they get down in the floor
if anybody's listening the best thing to
do is lay flat on the floor or put you
down a pad or a mattress you twist this
leg over then you twist that leg over
then you roll this back over and that
back over
and you can twist every of that weight
off of you
see look at me
you look perfect
and i'm just as limber as a dish right
cute as can be
darling thank you so much for talking
with me and sharing your story
you're amazing it's been wonderful
meeting you yeah likewise i wish you
maybe somebody will see something in
this we'll help them and they'll be
human a87
there will be 87 here to watch
four or five more months i bet you i'll
bet you're going to make it well past
100.
well my family used lips to be a hundred
and four or five yeah i don't i don't
see you slowing down anytime soon
not without something was to come up you
know it could getting a wreck or
anything can happen every day but you
don't worry about that you just keep a
trucking
but now one thing is we pick a lot of
huckleberries all over these little
ridges we pick our blackberries
put them away i've got peaches
apples put away i got pumpkins dinner in
the house new this winter
and uh
i think a lot of good healthy food is
good
but everybody don't live where they can
have hogs and stuff like others no they
don't
the reason you got to keep this land and
right now get it in five generations you
can put it i've got five generations you
can put it that they can't sell it that
long
or mortgage it
and i don't want either one you want to
play a little amazing grace for me
if you want me to
now when i get ready to go to bed
tonight that's usually what i do
amazing
[Music]
[Music]
but now
[Music]
my
[Music]
is
[Music]
lord i feel that holy spirit coming down
lord i feel like holy spirit
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
down
how's that
beautiful
that's all i have to have played
anything bothered me
lord i just feel that good spirit maybe
it's crazy
but i just feel that and i can just
march on
i feel like i can just march so far at
that time
i will not have
i
had to run out ahead beautiful ruby
thank you so much
oh lord now that'll make my day
i can sing it and i can really get on
and i think right there's a reason that
uh
it i don't uh
be sick or nothing yeah i play that
everybody could live like that wouldn't
the world be different
all this medicine could be cut out
everything
that'd be wonderful
i'm just an old clown woman
you've been here many many years
and if i can leave like this everybody
else can